ben shapiro's presence is a terror
organizers of a podcast conference in
dallas texas drew backlash thursday
after they took responsibility for harm
caused by the daily wire podcast host
ben shapiro's presence at the conference
podcast movement a major annual
conference for the podcast industry
issued a profuse apology on thursday
after attendees complained that shapiro
was spotted at the event near the daily
wire booth
remember that ben shapiro is one of the
two founders of the daily wire daily
wires sponsored this year's conference
in shapiro host of the massive massively
successful the bench bureau show podcast
was seen pictured walking around the
expo arena did you see the first tweet
that someone responded as a trans person
as a queer person as someone with a
uterus this does not make me feel
welcome this does not make me feel safe
one of the conference attendees posted
on twitter after sharing a picture of
shapiro standing by the daily wire booth
does ben shapiro make you feel you know
you know ben like quick speaking little
hat him does he make you feel
unsafe
um i we have to get beyond this unsafe
nonsense we have to stop taking it
seriously when anyone says it it's the
go-to thing isn't it
ben shapiro is not a threat to anyone he
just maybe has a different opinion than
you like just this is it's so childish
uh but it's happening all the time this
phrase unsafe it's been used against me
of course i've had the same thing i lost
a job because someone claimed that my
presence made them unsafe because of a
joke i'd told uh this sort of thing
happens all the time um when jerry sadow
is the the scottish comedian he had his
show pulled at the end of the fringe uh
last week um and the venue said that his
material was making people feel unsafe
so even now comedy promoters are
claiming that words are violence uh it's
i mean something you and i have
discussed before it's something that
we've been warning about for a long time
but look
we just need to start laughing in
people's faces when they say this stuff
it's absolutely ridiculous words are not
hurting you if you're offended then then
that's fair enough everyone gets
repented from time to time that's being
human but you're not physically harmed
the groveling apology from podcast
movement said hi folks we owe you an
apology before sessions kick off for the
day yesterday afternoon ben shapiro
briefly visited the pm 22 expo area near
the daily wire booth though he was not
registered or expected we take full
responsibility for the harm done by his
presence there's no way around it we
agreed to sell the daily wire at a first
time booth based on the company's large
presence in podcasting let's not forget
that they've got probably
two or three of the top 10 podcasts in
the world at any one time matt walsh
will be up there uh ben shapiro will be
up there the morning wire is
unbelievably huge it's this 15 minute
thing there's now making movies and blah
blah blah the weight of that decision is
now painfully clear shapiro is a
co-founder a drop in however unlikely
should have been considered a
possibility those of you who call this
unacceptable are right in nine wonderful
years growing and celebrating this
medium pm has made mistakes the pain
caused by this one will always stick
with us we promise that sponsors will be
more carefully considered moving forward
the pain it was a brief visit right he
said bench bureau briefly visited
if that's all it takes to to to
you know reduce you to connections then
you really need to see a doctor about
that because that
it's i mean i don't know what to do
about this sort of stuff i you know i've
been raining against it well you know
i've written a book now about it i'm i'm
i i think we need to stop tolerating it
i think we need to laugh it out of
existence i think i i think that there
is a very real place for ridicule to be
used here as one of the most important
uh pushback mechanisms because
the game that's being played a lot of
the time is this sort of faux
intellectual lexical overload semantic
game
brazilian jiu jitsu [ __ ] that's going
on
and
trying to engage with it on a serious
level
kind of legitimates the position that
the other side has whereas if you see
what happened with
uh pc
and then with the word woke how quickly
it became
you can't use the word woke
unironically anymore it's not a serious
term and the reason that that happened
is because people like yourself and
other comedians and online commentators
very quickly made it a caricature of
itself and yeah you can try and mandate
something or um how do you say
logically
reduce it down so that people don't want
to be associated with it but if you just
make it so uncool and socially toxic to
be associated with that no one wants to
use it anymore that's it dead in the
water yeah well i've tried that i mean
i've done a lot of the comedy stuff and
the satire stuff and i've written two
satirical books mocking this thing
my new book
is not that my new book is trying to get
to grips with it however what i would
say in my defense there
is i get what you're saying about you
know you can't really reason
but the the new book i've written isn't
aimed at the woke it is about the woke
and it's therefore an attempt
to uh because
most of the people who support who think
that they support the woke movement or
whatever we want to call them the
critical social justice movement
whatever
they don't really fully grasp what
they're about and so this is a book
where we talk through what where i try
and explain what it is that their
objectives are how really the culture
war is a
a battle over language and who gets to
define language i mean you've raised it
yourself there political correctness
woke i've got a whole section of the
book about the evolution of the word
woke and how it was a form of
self-identification for activists at one
point and then because people like me
started mock using the word to describe
them sometimes in a mocking way
they then started to pretend that it was
a right-wing term that people like me
had invented as an insult which isn't
true because you know we can check that
on google just go back people used to it
self-identifies work all the time there
are i've got screenshots of loads of
guardian articles talking unironically
about being woke
so that's not true
so um but but that's what they do is
that because this is a culture war about
language
uh these people who i call the new
puritans in my book
continually redefine language and then
they will tell you that they haven't
done so
so you're using words that you always
used to use but now they're telling you
they mean something different so you
used to think the word racism meant
prejudice or hate against someone due to
the color of their skin and now you're
told no it doesn't mean that it means an
equation prejudice plus power and it's
to do with power structures in society
and therefore white people uh non-white
people can't be racist and etc etc um
and you're told no the definitions
change now even though no one really
uses it in this way you we're telling
you it's it's done this way now what's
happening people if you enjoyed that
then press here for the full unedited
episode and don't forget to subscribe
peace
[Music]
you